le couvre feu n'aura pas suffi la
californie passe au confinement décision
ce jeudi du gouverneur just rien qu'au
cours des 14 derniers jours près d'un
millier de californiens ont perdu la vie
à cause du coc vie 19
le fait est que si nous n'agissons pas
maintenant notre système hospitalier va
être submergé si nous n'agissons pas
maintenant nous continuerons à voir le
taux de mortalité grimper et le nombre
de vies perdues augmenté interdiction de
se rassembler et de se déplacer sans une
bonne raison
fermeture des bars restaurants et arrêts
des services à la personne
seules les écoles et les infrastructures
jugées essentielles resteront ouvertes
la californie à l'arrêt pour au moins
trois semaines
car il y a urgence l'état a enregistré
plus de 18000 500 nouveaux cas
d'infection au coronavirus ce jeudi le
plus grand nombre de contaminations
recensés en 24 heures
depuis qu'a commencé la pandémie avec en
tête
los angeles pour tenter d'identifier les
personnes positives au co vide le comté
propose des tests sérologiques gratuit
je travaille dans une école j'ai une
famille j'ai trois filles et j'ai besoin
de savoir si j'ai été infectées si je
suis protégé je sais que ma famille et
mes filles sont protégés aussi c'est une
question de santé publique
et c'est un devoir civique de s'assurer
qu'on est en bonne santé
qu'on respecte la distanciation physique
et le port du masque
car si on ne le fait pas soi même
comment exiger des autres qu'ils le
fassent
il faut montrer l'exemple du côté des
commerçants plus difficile d'accepter
les mesures de restriction il nous
avions aménagé la terrasse extérieure
tout allait bien
encore une fois nous avons investi dans
le changement est l'adaptation de notre
entreprise pour qu'elle soit conforme en
ces temps de pandémie
et voilà que les changements reviennent
vous pouvez voir que les gens restent
chez eux
il est évidemment un couvre-feu remplace
il ya encore des changements et de
nouvelles règles
donc tout le monde s'adapte à cela et
c'est évidemment mauvais pour les
affaires
certains commerçants mécontents des
restrictions sanitaires ont lancé des
actions en justice contre l'état
les villes de pasadena et beverly hills
envisage-t-elle aussi de contester ces
mesures face à ces critiques le
gouverneur lance un avertissement
le comté pourrait bloquer ses
financements aux établissements qui
refusent d'appliquer les mesures
au total la californie comptabilise plus
de 1,26 million de cas et dix neuf mille
quatre cents décès depuis le début de
l'épidémie